[Music]
bella thorne turned heads in a cleavage
bearing corset and fringe skirt at the
la premiere of her new film
midnight sun you look amazing thank you
so much
bella dishing to e.t about her role
starring opposite patrick schwarzenegger
as a teen suffering a life-threatening
condition
a character who's locked away in her
room did it give you more appreciation
for your life today and all the things
that you do get to do
oh a hundred percent you know i've been
thinking about this for a while
growing up around you know kind of death
and sadness you realize that
one day you're there and the very next
day you you could not be you know and so
always keeping that mindset and i like
to complain about silly things and then
i'll look at myself and i'll be like
fella
come on who are you kidding it's not
gonna fall into remission and
every year the risk becomes more serious
you are launching
a beauty line which i think is so
amazing can you give me a little more
detail about that
uh well it's all organic which is cool
we have a lot of
acne infused products as in like helping
with of course it is makeup you know
but um one of the main things for me is
really just like
to actually take care of your skin with
a makeup brand you know me
struggling with so much acne always
constantly has that been a struggle oh
yeah i've always talked about how big of
a struggle it actually is
and so like um you know the overwhelming
fan tweets of
of people just being like how do you
control your skin and how do you wear
makeup and
actually covers you know and so i was
like this is
a good idea